[Music]
[Applause]
I started playing music I was
little I was seven
in reality I had no idea it could
become my main business
but after high school and decided that maybe
this  it could be the staircase because it
liked it hot this is my first
exchange in a european orchestra
we had the concept the boy in
madrid and now the last assault
and who drinks we feed knows salamanca
one thing that of
international music we can go and
play it anywhere  but thanks to
Europe
today it is easy to travel it
may be that in the morning we wake up in
madrid and in the evening we reserve in
stockholm
that is, I am not in salamanca in spain
yes it is beautiful no no no no do not
worry I do not pay the roaming were
little more the part that I prefer of the
musician who can often visit
different places and therefore with this
experience and European youth orchestras
I can also put together
the medications  i for two weeks that
we have been together one day and night
this facilitates the creation of a
deep v bond and therefore even when
we are on stage the contact with the
eyes
the understanding is stronger
too strong to play in an orchestra
with people who do not  they studied in
my country it was very interesting
because i realized that in the end
we are all very close despite the
language the different culture it was easy to
avoid contact and also play to
find a job
in the future for our family we are
playing bethoven mahler  rossini we have
many European composers and therefore
we have a common heritage that
we can send together
[Music]